[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young mom
who has a two-year-old who's just been
diagnosed with leukemia and she wants to
know how she can stay well
through the child's treatment we also
talked to a young woman who was recently
released from the hospital
and she wants to know how she can help
build her marriage
and we talked to a young man who's 21
and engaged
and mom doesn't know how to say she's
sad he's moving on
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show i hope you're doing
well
hope you are well if your family is well
i hope that you are finding kindness and
joy and if you're not
i hope you are closing your computer box
and you're being around people
who will lift you up pick you up
whether it's hard stuff good stuff bad
stuff i'm glad you're with us
glad you're walking alongside of us in
this wild wild
time hey um if you want to be on the
show we'd love to have you
we talk about anything everything all of
it um give me a call at one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one that's one eight four
four
six nine three three two nine one or go
to johndaloni.com
you can fill out the form it'll go to
kelly she'll hit delete you can do it
three or four more times
and it'll get through that's not really
true she won't just hit delete
um unless it's dumb and then she might
right
okay real quick this is so great
few things few things in my life make me
happier than when james childs is wrong
and he almost never is and so this is
like a good
thing for me um but listen
in i feel like this is my public service
announcement for
the james a child what's your middle
name
right like i'm going to say that oh
that's true
um i think i'm going to call him alan so
it's going to be james a
child james child by the way is not even
close to his real name it's an alias
um but listen a few months ago he
we're on the interwebs and he was making
fun of me about how whenever i get a
hard call i always
go like this because i don't know how to
transition and i'm new
to radio so then
you people came out and attacked
james in the most glorious lovely way
everybody went to war and was like hey
james once you back off the guy he's
trying his hardest
and i appreciated that but it's like
super continued
and so for everybody james has
acknowledged that he screwed up and that
he was wrong
and that he devalued the show with his
anti-horse
propaganda you remember we already
talked about this i know but over the
weekend man i got more and more
stuff like how dare he you need to get a
new listen i can't do this without james
how about that can i just say that out
loud
i don't know what i'm doing and i need
james a child you play the victim on the
air people don't realize how much of a
tyrant you are
we'll fix it in post is that how that
goes
i'm delete i hope i'm not a tyrant i'm
kidding you're not a tyrant
but i you are a tyrant
listen the other day i was late to
another show it was really bad
you should have seen the look of james
disappointment and sadness
so but listen in his defense let's all
just um
go switzerland on james no more mean
things to him we'll all just be neutral
if you can't say something nice let's
say nothing at all and his email address
um i will leave it in the show notes at
the end of the show so you can email him
directly how
upset you are that he hates horses so
much he won't even let me make their
noise
you realize i edit this show so i could
edit out all of that so awesome
if you edit it and just added me just
talking gibberish that'd be so great man
all right um let's go straight to the
phone zone we got a packed show
let's go to robin in rochester new york
robin what's going on hey john it's an
honor to talk
with you today how are you hey stop it
number one it's an honor to talk to you
and i'm doing good it's the sun shining
it's beautiful here in nashville so i
hope you're doing well what's up
the sun's shining here too and we don't
get many of those days in rochester yeah
you get like 11 a year that's super cool
way to go seriously though yeah um so
i'm a mom of three young kiddos okay
uh all under the age of five oh um
that's a lot of humans under
the in that age good for you it it is
it is and that would be enough of a
challenge
um but i also in january one of my
kiddos was diagnosed with leukemia oh no
which one which one my youngest his name
is jonathan he's
cute is jonathan beautiful
oh my gosh she's my world he's adorable
man i'm so sorry robin
thank you man so how can i help
you so he's he's doing really well um
he's about three months into his
treatment he has a super great prognosis
um his type of leukemia is like the most
common type of cancer in the in the
world
so yeah that's super not helpful though
right
i mean you're right listen right you're
already trying to steal the steer the
ship to like
so you know now listen this is not great
right
it's the best of the worst kind of news
right yes
exactly i'm so sorry for you so you got
this prognosis he's
three months in treatment and then what
yeah
um so we still have
probably about two years on treatment
for him
and that's assuming things go like
really great
yeah um as a mom of three
i'm constantly prioritizing other other
people
and realizing slowly that i'm not
taking care of me yeah and i really want
to come out
of the other side of this as a whole
person and i
i don't know how to do that ah gotcha i
love
that question and i'm gonna make a quick
note here
um okay so when you say you
you want to be whole and you're not
doing well that tells me you are already
feeling yourself fracture and splinter a
little bit what does that look like
so my day-to-day i'm pretty able to like
keep up with a
normal routine um
but then we'll get you know a medication
change or a new test result
or whatnot and i feel like i
it's all coming back to me and it's like
oh my gosh my kid has cancer my kid has
cancer and i just kind of
so you can medicate with a routine right
you can't
pacify it all and then when you have to
go see the doctor or
you've got to give a shot or your kid
hurts or
and then it all comes back huh yes okay
what what does living in um
i wish i had a better what does living
in crisis mode feel like look like for
you
i mean some days i do fairly well with
it some days i
i'm exercising i'm eating right
i'm taking fairly decent care of myself
and some days
it's just too much and i'm you know
eating things i shouldn't because i'm
trying to
just get through the day and i'm on my
phone too much and i'm
you know fighting with my husband
because we
are dealing with this in very different
ways and
um so like i say some days are great
some days are not
so i'm going to give you i'm going to
ask one more question and then
we can rattle off some things together
here um but then we'll talk about some
big rocks is that cool
yeah have you had
the moment where you were driving or you
looked in a mirror by yourself
in your bathroom or passing in like in a
hallway
and you thought oh my god i did this
this is my fault
no i wouldn't necessarily say i i don't
think it's my fault
okay you are already way ahead of the
game then
so good good good that makes my heart
feel good the thing that
is almost the most devastating for young
family families especially
is with any sort of illness is
this came from my body and the fact that
you're not wrestling with that guilt
that makes my heart feel so good because
obviously this isn't your fault so
that's so good
okay are you ready to party here
sure what does your marriage look like
right now
um my marriage is is really pretty good
um i have an amazing husband he
is just an amazing father and provider
and um but day to day he's
he's at work um so i'm dealing with a
great majority of
appointments and you know a lot of the
difficulties of blood draws etc
so i try to kind of explain what's going
on
um with all of that but it's just he's
just hearing it he's not experiencing it
um and how we are dealing with this i'm
i'm a planner so i wanna like figure out
what all of this is going to look like
a month from now two months from now
five months from now and he's
much better at being day to day which
honestly i
am thankful for yeah um but sometimes
that means
i'm trying to wrap my head around things
and he's
you know he's just not he's like nope
don't i don't want to think about that
gotcha so sometimes the default to being
a future planner
is a false way of trying to grab control
and drag it into your present so
it becomes this illusion that if i have
everything on the calendar in the right
way and i know all the medications that
i know the right thing this and then
this and then this and this
then this is how this is going to play
out and nobody knows
more than you that that's not how that
works but it's
such a it's such a drug to plan and have
a list
in the spreadsheet on the computer so
that
right and it is important and then i'm
more like your husband that's like dude
we got today let's just party
and eat nachos and we'll figure out
tomorrow tomorrow that's not helpful
either
that's another kind of drug which is
just pretending none of this is real
but there is a balance there right okay
so
here's an important thing so right
before this call kelly let me know this
call
was coming and i talked to uh um
a buddy i work with here who's had a
similar situation whose
young child was just diagnosed with
cancer a little while ago
and they've been working through this
and i said man give me a couple of
thoughts that are rattling around your
head what are some things you're working
on or things that are hard
and i can make this an intellectual
exercise i haven't experienced this
he has and i'm going to tell you a
couple things he gave me that were so
wise
and i i loved how he framed it
the most important thing over the top of
this thing especially since gent
wrestling with guilt is this
this is your story and you get to write
how you experience it and how you work
your way through it
okay what type of parents do you want to
be in this process
and if you think about this as a story
and that you are the person holding the
pen
and you get to author these characters
then you get to be in control of
do we smash things do we lose things do
we just just
like eat cheetos for the next four years
until those things
like we get to be you get to draft what
these characters look like right
and the second part of this that was
equally important is
it's important to continually tell this
story and um
my friends that have had cancer they
talk about how annoying it is because
they immediately have to be the person
who's taking care of everybody else in
their circle
because that you know somebody will see
them they're like and then suddenly
you've got somebody else sobbing and
crying and you're like dude it's my kid
what are you doing
right but you have to make them feel
better and so
there's something about telling the
story telling the facts of this thing
that as you mentioned it keeps it from
surprising you when you are having that
moment like oh my gosh my kids got
cancer right
it lets you retain ownership of this
when you're telling that story
and at the same time it helps you be
graceful not if but when people say
stupid stupid dumb idiotic moronic
things
would you tell the audience like what's
the stupidest thing somebody said to you
um i mean i think the one that bothers
me the most is like
we're believing for complete healing and
that's not
like i i believe for it too but i guess
i
i want to trust that this is like god's
doing something
in all of our lives through this and so
i guess just wishing it away
seems so kind of silly in some ways
but yeah people definitely say things
but it's like
it's like really well
yes yes um i've been standing there with
folks who are doing death notifications
before and it's like
i have to interrupt them because i
realize oh gosh you can't say those
words out loud to another person right
so it is up to you unfortunately to
decide
to hear those things and just set them
down because if you carry them that
anger and that frustration and that
just it'll melt you right and it will
weigh you down they're going to have
done their good deed for the day when
they dropped off their casserole and
said we just
this is all going to be over soon hit
right and you're just
thinking i just did a blood draw on my
two-year-old how are you doing
right it's being able to just put that
down
and balance it with this and this is
super important you
have to have to have to have other
people that you can sit down and talk to
and be open with and
bang your head and your hands on a table
and scream this isn't fair
and that will tell you jokes and it will
sneak you cigarettes whatever the thing
is that you shouldn't have done that you
you know used to in high school now
it's coming back all that stuff is going
to sneak you cheeseburgers and you
shouldn't be eating them
and also say stop eating cheeseburgers
you need people who will go through this
with you
do you have a group um parents who have
experienced this did the hospital
connect you with some folks that you've
set and met with
yeah yeah we do good good we do we're
definitely working on developing that
community more as well
and this is impo this is i wouldn't have
thought about this but he mentioned this
every family is going to have a
different story they're going to have
different interactions with the doctors
different parent pressures different
in-law pressures different responses to
different medications
and so do that weird hard thing which is
be in community and remember this is
your story
and your kid may be the one that
responds so so so good
and the three other people in this
group's kids didn't or vice versa
right and it's remembering this is your
story and you need other people
um and never be afraid to distance
yourself from absolute idiots
and there will be such great morons
have you had morons just emerge over and
over and over
uh yeah yeah definitely
your um dismissive laugh is maybe my
favorite thing of the whole day
you're like yeah there's people who have
totally ruined our day
i love it it makes me happy okay
you will not survive this if your
relationship with your husband
falls apart and
most not most a number of relationships
i shouldn't have said most a number of
relationships
don't survive these type of traumas
because as you mentioned it
people do grief differently and it is
super important that
um partners build in conversations they
build in space to communicate and check
in with one another and there is
no comparative grief going on at all
because if you haven't had it already
there will come a weekend when you can't
get out of bed
and your husband's gonna have to step in
there and slide right in
and run with it and that is gonna also
circle back on him too
and y'all are gonna have to be graceful
and kind and show up
and over like the toilet sick
with grief and laughing so hard you
can't breathe because that's
you know your body's trying to handle it
but you all have to tie in with one
another
um i would strongly with all my guts
recommend a weekly check-in
with the two of you whether you go for a
walk around the block that
and if those knuckleheads call what can
we do what can we do cool show up at my
house
every sunday night at eight o'clock
because me and my husband will be gone
for two hours
and make them feel super guilty for not
coming by the way
just kidding don't do that but having a
group that will show up and then
practice being graceful with one another
are y'all able to talk about
the realities of this how scary how hard
how good how
it bad it could have been how much left
we don't how much left there is that you
don't know are y'all able to do that
with each other
yeah yeah i think we are even though we
process differently we've
we've been able to kind of um step into
each other's shoes and
and see that yeah it may be super
helpful to have a go get a nice one like
spend some money
and get a nice journal that you both can
write back and forth in and it can stay
on your pillow on your bed and one of
you
y'all just agree that every couple days
the other person will write in it
it can be a way for you to get your
unfiltered thoughts out without also
reading his eye movements and his
eye rolls and the way he's clinching his
forehead right it can let you be
unprocessed and unbiased and unfiltered
and put those thoughts down
and then he can read them and check in
and then he can write right
and sometimes people get separate in
their grief because they think the other
person is thinking different things and
they're actually thinking
and you end up on two different planets
writing it down and having a way that
you can process
it's almost like remember when you're
like in middle school elementary school
you had those notebooks and you'd write
in them and hand them to your friends
that may have been when i was a kid i
guess now you just text back and forth
but
it's a way to keep up with one another
and then here's the last uh two things
number one listen to the doctors
and for god's sakes not the internet
okay
have you been down the uh webmd rabbit
hole yet
yes yeah yeah it's bad it's bad
what does that even mean well
um i would say i've been down the
facebook rabbit holes there are
facebook a lot of facebook groups for
this diagnosis and the problem is is
that again
like you said it's different people
different stories
so you know and it's a competition to
who
who out sucks the other person
right like whose life is worse than the
others like oh yeah well this happened
to me like oh yeah
this and this and this happened oh gosh
stay off facebook for god's sake stay
off facebook right
okay or just make a little tiny
community and just say
just say positive things or nothing
otherwise
you're an idiot like yeah just don't go
down listen to your doctors
and if you ever have the gut feeling
they're not telling you the truth and
i'm being open with you challenge them
this is your child this is your baby and
i'm confident that you're already there
here's the last thing
hug love and
hold this little two-year-old
accountable in the same way you would
your other kids
and you want him the challenge is going
to be you want to just give him a pass
on everything right because he's got
cancer for crying out loud
yeah but let him also be a little boy
and let him also say hey i asked you to
bring your
plate over right go back and get your
plate or we don't hit or
still hold him accountable and let him
see that he is a part of this
functioning family he is just like his
older brothers older sisters
i don't know what the other two are but
he is just like them and he is still
a learning developing little boy who
also is
has this additional challenge when you
get done when this thing is through
and he is well and he is healed and he
is whole
he will have this two parents who still
gave him little boy boundaries
they still um held him accountable they
still hugged the crap
out of him all the time and they still
uh wrapped him up in all sorts of joy
but not bubble tape
they listen to the doctors and now he's
got strength
and he's got character he's got two
parents that he knows will go to the end
of the earth for him
and now he's got a story to tell because
mom and dad took the pin when this thing
started and said here's who we're going
to be through this process
and never forgetting that you're the
authors of this thing
and be real real real real graceful for
yourself there are some days that
cheeseburgers are all it's gonna matter
and i'm giving you full permission to
crush them okay
crush them and hey bring your other kids
in on this thing too
do you give them jobs do you give them
some like opportunities to help and be a
part of this
yeah yeah absolutely ah so good that's
so good
hey here's the thing you are
you are down the road in this thing when
you think of being whole when this is
all over
robin whole is not going to be what once
was
hold is going to be something totally
new and you're going to have scars
and you're going to um growth you're
gonna have new branches that you didn't
even know existed
you're going to have cried harder than
you
knew possible your marriage is gonna be
stronger in a way that you wish it
wasn't so strong because it only gets
this strong through strain and stress
but a hole is not going to be what it
once was it's going to be new
and that new is going to be
extraordinary and you can shine it it's
still going to have
dents and seams in it where it was
welded back but it's also gonna have
new and strong and beautiful and i'm so
excited for this journey
keep us keep us in the loop on how
things are going
how your family's doing and if i can
help at all let me know
i'm so grateful for the call um
this is your story and you get to write
it and you don't know how the ending's
going to be but you get to write who the
characters are going to be
in this story all right let's go to ann
in tulsa oklahoma
and what's up hey how are you
i'm super good how are you doing okay
really happy to be on the show just
thrilled well i'm glad that you called
i'm thrilled as well
so we're double thrilled what's up how
can i help
so um a few weeks ago i was
hospitalized for suicidal ideation
okay um i'm home now and i'm back at
work
but things are still i mean kind of
weird
kind of different and i really just
wanted to know
you know how can i walk through this
season well
especially with my husband what a great
question okay so you are married you
have any kids
no no kids so tell me about what
happened what what happened and how did
you end up
in hospital yeah so i have
a history of trauma okay and
been diagnosed with ptsd and
i started having these panic attacks and
in the panic attacks
you know i would really believe that
people would be better off just without
me and so i was having
a really horrible panic attack and
believing that
and it was like something just snapped
and i was like okay well i need to find
the best way to i mean kill myself
and luckily my husband and i were able
to
see my usual counselor and
you know we talked to her about what's
been going on and
you know i just i got to that point
where i was not
confident that i could promise to keep
myself
safe and so they decided that it would
be best for me to go inpatient for a
while
and did kind of changed up some
medicine um
learn some new coping tools and so and
so you've been out for a few weeks
yes and how are you feeling now that
you're back home
um it's weird things are starting to get
back to normal every once in a while
like i'll do something with my husband
and you know i'll feel that joy again
we're getting there then there's also
things that
are just really weird like what's weird
you know our medicine
well our medicine's locked now yeah and
like we're having to really pay close
attention to
like what we do and don't do to try to
avoid
like triggers and just not get too tired
so that i end up
a mess and i just feel really
embarrassed that i was there in the
first place
because like on the outside i'm still
holding it together
really well and not a lot of people know
what actually happened
okay so i want to
change this the the ending here okay
there won't be a back to normal and i
would recommend never using that phrase
again
and i would even suggest you don't want
to be back to normal because back to
normal was full of panic attacks and
trauma memories
both both in your mind and your body's
response
right and trauma the back to normal
normal sucked it wasn't good right
and so what we're doing now is we are
building a new tomorrow that's going to
be different and stronger and more
secure
and more extraordinary than anything
the people who hurt you could have
imagined for you anything that you and
you married this
great guy could have imagined anything
that you had in your
in your heart and mind that's where
we're going now
and so sometimes the burden the weight
of trying to
drag around what was into our present is
so exhausting
dude i'm just out i'm done right there's
a whole new energy with
the excitement of building something new
and the excitement of here's where we're
going
and it's gonna we're gonna stumble and
trip and fall and think god you've got
an awesome guy
walking alongside you but this is where
we're headed and it's going to be so rad
when we get there
by the way you're never going to get
there the the big sucker punch in all
this is
that it is where you're headed right
it's awesome um
so here's a couple things you may know
this about your husband but
you scared him to death right is that
fair
yes okay is he doing the best he can
however good or misguided but is he
doing the best he can to love you with
the tools he's got
yes absolutely okay so i want you to
always keep that in your heart and mind
when it gets super
frustrating you can't just go get some
advil or it gets super annoying that you
just want diet coke and they have locked
whatever the thing is right you and your
doctors
just breathe whoo and realize that
stupid knuckleheads trying to love me
again
right and again and again did y'all
create a
usually they'll do it together if you've
got a partner that's willing to did you
all co-create a wellness plan together
well we did one of the hospitals but it
was kind of like a rush
part of the i mean discharge i guess
okay and i haven't gone over it in
detail with
my husband and so i probably should yeah
so here's what i would do i would take
that
and i would let your counselor know that
you're doing this but you and him can
work together
on building a wellness plan that
includes both of you
and he will be able to walk with firmer
footing because you're going to give him
permission to
when you see me not get out of bed two
days in a row you have permission to
call my counselor
and my counselor's got permission to
talk to you because you love me and you
don't like that i'm about to say this
and but you're only two weeks out that's
not a very long time
and so for you this feels like oh it's
over
i would tell you you're still in it okay
and you are still
um like you've seen like a baby giraffe
on the national geographic whatever like
those wobbly feet that's where you're at
right now
and that's good that's awesome you've
got people who love you you've got
um doctors surrounded you've got
resources and that's all good
but except that he's trying to love you
and coach him and
when he has a wellness plan that he can
live into
great and you get to speak into that too
and that may mean
hey i do not at all ever want your
advice
ever ever never give me advice i hate it
i don't want it
just hug me um and man every guy i know
who's had somebody
who's tried to commit suicide in their
world just man they read everything they
can and are just throwing facts at these
poor people
and it's not helpful right so
um this this wellness plan that you all
co-create together and i'd love it if
you did it with your counselor too all
three of you would be awesome
um but it lets you develop an honesty
and it's a strength that you're going to
develop which is i need this
from you and you've probably never had
permission to say those words out loud
because you're a trauma survivor
and he's going to say i see this in you
and i
we've already talked about it i'm going
to help in this way and that way he's
not guessing and throwing things off
into the moon
and then the last thing here is you have
to promise
and swear and participate in some
ancient
um bonding ritual i don't know whatever
it is like you've gotta swear
promise cross your heart hope to die
stick a noodle in your eye
that if you ever have dark thoughts
again you're going to let them know then
you're going to call somebody
do you promise promise promise that
yes that didn't sound very convincing
that sounded like they told you that at
the hospital and you said i will so
they would let you leave no
i mean it's tough it's hard i mean
even though i know it's the right thing
to do it's hard to see
the pain that that causes whenever you
let
i mean your husband know what's
happening
and i would say all the time well yeah
of course you do you can do hard things
and it is pain but it's a it's it's
it's pain because he loves you so much
it's pain because he's in this with you
right
he is your right or die and so it's not
pain at him it's pain with him and
that's totally different
this is pain he signed up for right he
is in it and that's what he's for and
there will come a day when
he's going to lean on you if he hasn't
already my guess is he probably has
already
what is your what is part of your
um personal wellness journey what's your
arc with
dealing with this trauma who who are you
going to become
in light of this i really want to become
a person that
can advocate for other people that have
been through
the same stuff that i have done and just
okay but
then it's okay before you do that i want
you to advocate for anne
yeah and so easy it's easy to blow by
what just happened with you to blow by
your feelings blow by your traumas and
start focusing on helping other people
and you got to help you you've got to
believe that you're worthy of
all this wellness and love that's coming
your way part of the thing that really
annoys you
is that you don't think you're worthy of
helping and your husband does
and then he shows up and it drives you
crazy right
that's accurate and you're super annoyed
that your stupid counselor keeps
checking in on you because who are you
right the best way you can
advocate for other people
is to do the hard gritty messy bloody
yucky mess
hard work of getting well of
processing those traumas taking them out
of your body for good
they are a part of you they always will
be but they won't set off every alarm
you have
they won't make you so exhausted they
won't send your body off into
um just spinning out and spitting out to
where the only solution to make this
thing
is to make this thing stop right
right and it just gets exhausting is
that right
yeah absolutely often people don't
understand if they haven't sat by
somebody who's experiencing this
they don't understand it makes sense is
it ring true with you and i
the most common thing i've heard when
i've sat with people who have attempted
suicide or about to
is i'm so tired i just need this to stop
yes does that ring true
yeah okay so today it's two weeks later
how are you feeling i'm still
tired yeah um
but hopeful you know a lot of good
things came out of that
and tell me what two of them were
um i actually made friends
while i was
hey how cool is it and i'm laughing
because that's one of the most common
things i hear like i got two new bros
listen i do how how
cool is it though okay
i'll back it up tell me if this is your
experience you went in there
the next morning because the first thing
they do is they make you sleep right so
the next morning you wake up
and you see a group of people and you're
like whoa
i'm not that right did you have that
experience
shooting some people were some of them i
was like okay
i'm not the odd one out here but there
were others but yeah
okay so you're shoes you're so kind the
two responses are number one
oh my gosh i'm not alone i thought i was
nuts i'm not alone
and number two okay they're super neat
to be here
i don't right and then you start
thinking what am i doing i get
embarrassed
right so here's the thing the people who
loved you
the professionals in your life they said
this is the right place for you
and they did the right thing you did a
brave right thing um
you've got zero zero zero reason to
feel embarrassed or ashamed okay the
same as if you broke your ankle
and you went to the doctor to get a cast
on it you wouldn't come out and people
would be like oh it's so lame you got a
cast
you gotta actually on your broken ankle
dumb same thing
okay or if you severed a finger that you
went and got it sewed back on
no one would give you a hard time about
that this is the same situation
you had some challenges you went and saw
the right professional care you were
brave and went to the doctor and they
took care of you and so i'm so glad
you're still with us
so glad you made this call and now it's
about
who you're gonna be you are not a
lone anne do you promise me when i tell
you that
yeah and i don't know if you've listened
to the show but one promise i make is i
won't lie to anybody
and so if i didn't believe this i
wouldn't tell you you are
absolutely worth being here tomorrow and
the next day and every day after that
the world will be a darker place without
you here okay
i know you don't fully believe when i
say that yet you're two weeks out and
that's okay
but i want you to continue to use that
as a touchstone and your husband
who has a whole lot more impact in your
life than some idiot on the radio does
he tells you the same thing okay yeah
we're glad you're here and you're worth
being here okay
now the fun adventurous exciting part of
what comes next
there is no back to normal it's all new
from here
and that's the most exciting fun part
because you get to create and build what
that's going to look like and
so glad that you got somebody you can
ride with and you met
two new folks in on the inside
and y'all can be best friends forever
you probably won't be
but hey it is super fun that you've got
those folks make sure you stay connected
to your doctor
make sure make sure you stay connected
to your counselor make sure you stay
plugged in with your husband
you all co-create a plan together so he
knows how he can best love and serve you
you know how you can slowly start taking
these steps
on standing up tall letting your voice
be heard letting what you say
matters what you want matters and you
promised in front of
a lot of people a lot of people you
promised
that if you ever have a dark moments
again if you ever think about hurt
yourself again you're going to reach out
and we're going to hold you to it and
we're going to hold you to it
okay thank you so so much for your call
we love you and we're so glad you're
with us
i cannot wait i cannot wait to see
the exciting things you have ahead of
you i can't wait to see
the grind and how hard it's going to be
in the little step after a little step
after a little step it's not going to be
easy
but i can't wait to see your journey
from here thank you so so much for this
call ann
all right um so we're gonna totally
switch gears here my friend wayne
sent me this article and i
immediately read it and thought i can't
believe i haven't
thought of this because i say some of
these things
but then i thought oh gosh i may be
wrong and so i need to make sure
that i'm not an idiot and so
um and those aren't mutually exclusive
here so i'm just going to read you a
couple of things
it's an article by a guy named pete ross
now listen i don't know anything about
pete i never met pete i don't know
pete um and so pete may be the worst guy
ever i don't think so
he's probably a great guy too he may be
just fine i don't know pete ross
so partridge in a pear tree but here's
what
um the article talks about and
it's fascinating uh just a quick quick
snippets
in 2020 outrage is the latest drug of
society
it's more acceptable than alcohol it's
more addictive than anything you can
swallow smoke or inject because while
heroin and meth are clearly harmful
anger feels so righteous after all
it's the other political party that's
ruining the world their supporters hate
america
people are too selfish we're not doing
enough for the poor we're not doing
enough for the one percent women don't
have enough rights men don't have enough
rights those people are racist though
that group doesn't even recognize their
privilege
and on and on and he goes to write we
love being angry because it makes us
feel
smart that reminds me of an article that
a guy named dr stoney wrote in
psychology today
i think this year or two ago anger
we blame somebody when we get angry
because it sets off our adrenaline
and we have to have adrenaline for fight
or flight and you can become addicted to
that anger
when you get angry it makes you feel
smart it makes you feel a little bit of
power which you need in a moment if
you're going to take off sprinting if
you're going to turn and fight a bear
and it tells us that we're the ones that
need to be in charge
right that we call someone out or worse
we try to ruin their careers because
they deserve it because i'm right
and and and an outrage
sells like crazy because it's a strong
emotion and strong emotions force people
into action
that's why political parties instead of
just solving problems
which nobody will do instead of solving
problems
they whip their supporters into a frenzy
i'm still reading here
whip their supporters into a frenzy of
anger against whatever other side is
corporations are now getting involved
they weaponize your outrage to sell
their products
now you all know my thoughts on
technology how they create these
ecosystems right and i'm a part of it i
get it too feel free to
move right on right but this is a
thought i hadn't considered
before now here's what he writes now
rather than get on my high horse and
tell you that you're being played for a
fool
and you should stop participating in the
media blah blah blah
i just want to ask one question how is
this working out for you
has constantly reading liking retweeting
or commenting your outrage made your
life
any better has it helped any of the
injustices that you're actually trying
to fight
what's it actually doing for you has it
helped you earn more work
be better with your family has it made
you more fulfilled has it helped solve
the insanity of systemic racism and
poverty and hate and political divide
has it helped he writes my guess is it
just made you even more pissed off and
angry
so he ends it with here's a better idea
what if we use that time and energy to
actively better your life
and the lives of those around you
if you don't do that and keep being
outraged by everything your anger is
going to consume you
or if somebody says something outrageous
that you disagree with
don't give them smoke don't give them
the fire
simply go outside and serve somebody
simply go outside and join the march
the peaceful protest simply go outside
and invite someone to your house
who's hungry be about these solutions
not outraged by them now here's the
thing
he ends with this it's important to
remember that yes there are more
injustices than you can shake a stick at
you all know me well enough there are so
much disgust and
evil and ugliness out there over and
over and over and over
but thumbs downing something or mean
comments just simply aren't helping
if you want to take somebody's power
away take their voice away
just walk away because you know what if
the injustice machine i mean nothing
just if the outrage machine doesn't get
the clicks they'll stop putting the
stories up
they'll stop it'll just end because
they're not getting anything right
so i i hadn't thought of this idea that
outrage is ruining people's lives in
this direct way
and outrage is important when you see
something disgusting you got to step up
and you got to step in
but i don't know if media fights media
screaming is the way to do it
and i've gotten suckered into this the
last year especially through the
political season of
man going to war and being loud i've got
away from some of my core principles
with thought which are i'm gonna love
local
i'm gonna take care of people in my
community and i'm gonna go out of my way
to make sure people are
are in my sphere are taken care of and i
hope
that when you feel anger rise up in you
and you recognize that it's pointing you
towards something you care about
that your solution is to go get involved
in care
face to face person to person heart to
heart
and not just to join the outrage parade
i love that question it's from the old
american history x how is this
working out for you how is this making
your life better it's a great question
we should all ask ourselves and more
importantly
how should how is this helping other
people's lives
those who are suffering these injustices
all right gwen thanks for sending this
on man um it gives me something to think
about i'd love to hear your thoughts so
feel free to
email us back or um shoot me on the
internets at johndaloni
you can follow me there all right let's
take one more call let's go to kevin
in san antonio what's up kevin
how are you man i'm so good how about
you i'm great thanks for having
me on and thank you for all you do i'm a
big fan hey thanks brother i appreciate
you calling in
and i love me some san antonio man
it's really it's the best it's the best
all right man so what's up
so i am 21 engaged and i'm getting ready
to move out
but i think my mom is manipulating my
situation a little bit to influence
where i move
and i need help navigating it okay so
what is getting ready to move out mean
uh well i am finishing up college and
have
job offers in two very different cities
one is austin texas the other is in
washington dc
okay and uh after narrowing it down to
those two cities
you know she is very much wanting me to
move towards
austin it's like two hours away or an
hour and a half away or 90 minutes away
yeah all right yes sir so how is she
manipulating you what does that even
mean
well uh every time that i bring up the
dc option
which is a viable option it's uh both
viable for myself
for my fiance she tries her best to
shoot it down
and any in every way she can she's
fights it's too expensive it's not safe
i'm making a mistake i'm missing up i'm
missing out on an opportunity
a great opportunity in austin and uh
whenever
i defend the option for the sake of
having a conversation
she will shut down and say well i guess
i don't get an opinion then do
i and uh kind of guilts me about it
you know and so i'll try to talk to her
and she's you know kevin
i i just don't want you to ruin your
life and you know i'm really telling you
what i think is best
and uh i think i think the worst part is
that she's she's said that i'm being
manipulated by my fiance and that i just
can't see it because i'm too deep in the
middle of everything
and that i am you know i can't see
anything
very clearly but uh but that she can and
so
like i said it's gotten difficult um so
here's the story kevin
one time i was gonna move somewhere far
away
and someone i loved
called me and we had a hard conversation
and on the phone they said some things
about
my lack of planning what i didn't know
about where i was going
the amount of research i had or hadn't
done what kind of parent
am i to be doing x y and z
taking my kid to place x y and z right
right
and dude i got pissed it was like dude
how dare you
right like i don't know a lot but i at
least know the research where i'm moving
my child
and i at least know that of course i've
involved my wife in this
and in your case your fiance you can
call it manipulation if you want but i'm
choosing to hitch my wagon to somebody
for the rest of our lives and so of
course they have a say in this
not only do they have a say but their
life's involved too so they have
their feelings and hearts and principles
and facts all of that right
right and then it hit me we were not
having a fact
discussion at all had nothing to do with
that
and while the person was responding to
my phone call
i took the phone a couple inches away
from my ear
and i started quietly whispering to
myself
john i love you and i don't know how to
say it
and so i'm doing the best i can john i
love you
i don't know how to say it and so i'm
doing the best i can
and here's what your mom's telling you
right now kevin she loves you
she doesn't want you to go away not
because she doesn't think you can make
it of course you can
not because if you went to washington dc
and became president she wouldn't be the
proudest mom on planet earth
that's right because she loves you
you've been living at home
she's gonna miss you she's about to turn
you over to some other lady
right that's never gonna cook her
casserole like she does
she's never gonna love her baby boy like
she does and it's coming out
all sideways and so
when she gives you her thoughts on i
think austin's the best option and
you're just being stupid naive and
dumb and idiotic and being swindled by
some girl who's happened that's going to
be her daughter-in-law's pretty soon
yeah i want you to hug her and say thank
you so much for
letting me know and giving me your
insights that means a lot you've seen a
lot of stuff and i appreciate it
and then kevin she doesn't get a vote
brother
it doesn't matter what she wants
you've got to do what's right for you
and your wife
and your career and here's the thing you
don't know where your career is going to
go
you don't know what tomorrow's going to
look like you can be in austin for 13
days
and then the city is going to freeze
again or it's going to melt or you're
going to have to move anyway or you can
go to dc
and who dude don't overthink it
and any move you make right now is not
forever i'm gonna suggest you take the
more adventurous route
take the craziest option the option that
has the biggest risk and payoff the one
that's going to make you work the
hardest and have to stay up the latest
and make you and your new wife have to
learn the most about each other
because you're what how old are you i'm
21. yeah dude you are just getting
rolling the 20s are
where it's at because you can run and
run
and run and grind and learn and learn
and do it
and you're lucky enough to have somebody
by your side in this process who's like
dude i'm all ride or die kevin forever
and um man don't overthink your mom
she's not manipulating you she is but i
wouldn't look at it that way
i would look at it as she's trying to
say i love you
and the only language she knows is
spanish and you're speaking italian
and honor her for what she's trying to
do and then
man put in your back pocket move on your
day at the end of the day you got to
make a call
now here's the big question i've got for
you are you going to dc or austin you
already know
well i i think i'm going to dc now i
i've been talking out on the job side of
it with my fiance and i i think that dc
is going to end up being more viable so
okay it really has been a decision
in in the making up until even just you
know five minutes ago when she and i
have still been talking it out
but sweet so i think it's gonna end up
being in dc make your call
be a person of character tell your mom
to her face
and um she's gonna be sad she's gonna be
angry she's gonna be frustrated
it's not because you're stupid it's
because her little baby boy is growing
up and moving out
and i want to honor my mom in that
moment it's hard for everybody
she's going to say something she regrets
and she's probably going to say some
things that hurt
it is what it is and she's still your
mom and
if you can hear it as i love you and i
don't know how to say it the right way
so this i'm doing the best i can if you
can hear it in that way then you can
move on brother
and then of course if she becomes a
toxic lunatic
and sends you mean text all the time and
calls you and leaves um guilt trip
messages
at some point you're gonna draw
boundaries and cut that out but as she's
watching her baby boy graduate college
hitch himself to another woman and move
halfway across the country
i'm gonna give my mom that moment of
heartbrokenness on 50 different fronts
right
i'm not gonna be her punching bag but
i'm gonna i'm gonna believe that she is
doing the best she can to tell me she
loves me
i'm not gonna carry that baggage around
i'm not right
and you don't have to either you are
heading off to somewhere awesome and
here's the thing
you go to you go to uh dc and it sucks
and you're there for six months and you
and your friend and your wife are like
well this is stupid come back to austin
with your head held high take your mom
out for some dope mexican food and say
tol you told me so congratulations i'm
buying dinner
and then take your austin job and you'll
be right back where you were it'll be
awesome
or here's what's going to happen she's
going to come visit you in six months
you're gonna take her to the smithsonian
you're gonna take her some cool spots in
dc
that you know that nobody else knows
because it's cool she's gonna be all
in and then she's gonna start talking
about buying a condo out there that's
just how it's gonna go
just remember hey kevin i love you and i
don't know how to say
it and i'm gonna miss you so so so much
and i don't know how to say it
so i'm just gonna tell you you're stupid
and i want you to move down the street
from mom right
thank you so much for the call brother
kevin all right um here's the thing
this is a big moment for me the other
night i was at an event
and this happened i met meatloaf
i met meatloaf the guy the legend
and i didn't even know what to say it
was so i don't get star struck ever
just i just don't and i saw i saw mr the
loaf
and i walked straight up to him and i
was like hey meet you and i are bros
you're about 50 years older than me and
your life's been infinitely different
than mine but
you're awesome and we hung out for a
while he was
as delightful and hilarious in whatever
you could imagine
and then i got home and my wife was half
asleep like just hanging on i said hey
baby i'm just going to let you know i'm
home
and she's like all right good night and
i said and by the way
um tonight i partied with meatloaf
and she was just like whatever and then
she started to fade out and she
sat back up and goes did you find out
what that one thing he won't do for love
is
to which i died laughing and i was like
i didn't ask i forgot and she's like
idiot and then she just laid back down
to go to sleep and so in honor
of mr the loaf
and one of the strangest evenings of my
life
this song is off the rock the planet
album i don't even know what year
probably 1804.
um this is the song i do anything for
love
but i won't do that and it goes like
this
and i would do anything for love i'd run
right into hell and back i would do
anything for love
i'll never lie to you and that's a fact
but i'll never forget the way you feel
right now oh no no way
and i would do anything for love but i
won't do that
anything for love i would do anything
for love but i won't do that and some
days it don't come easy and some days it
don't come
hard some days it don't come at all and
those are the days that never end and
some nights you're breathing
fire and some nights you're carved in
ice and some nights you're like nothing
i've ever seen before or will again
and maybe i'm crazy oh it's crazy and
it's true
i know you can save me no one else can
save me
but you and i would do anything for love
but i won't do that and i don't know
what that is and such as this show
this has been the dr john dalone show
you